what's up good evening good afternoon I
wanted to read I wanted to read through
the comments of one of the videos for a
long time I've been meaning to look at a
video and read the comments and react to
them in real time so I want to do that
today with the recent is the most recent
estefy can with the oman number 273 and
this is with a gun man we interviewed
this gun man
Sunday yesterday on Easter and it was
quite the time and and I learned a lot
and so I'm just gonna read through some
of the comments and uh and that'll be it
I haven't seen the comments yet on this
so Theo looks like a father who is going
to court about the custody of his job
about the custody of his children
that is true I do like that because I
had on that Easter shirt that's why man
I had that all on that beautiful pastel
upper piece man beautiful beautiful
shirt I've having about four years and
only wear probably once a year
Theo is dressed like the best
congresswoman the O is dressed like the
best do is dress sorry
the O is true the O is dressed like the
best congresswoman in the south and that
is true set man shout out Pat Summitt
that [ __ ] is I definitely have that most
savage the most savage look for
congresswoman right there you know what
I'm saying my guest today is a man that
I met at the gun store and that's true
that's who that man was
Nico Theo looks like somebody's aunt
that can't wait for the quarantine in
and some t.j.maxx can reopen I like it
Joe exotic licking his lips to listen to
this interview in jail and true story we
were supposed to have an interview with
Joe exotic audio a phone audio interview
but he got put in a quarantine because
uh because corvid got him so we'll see
what happens next
Thea looks like one of Joe exotics
ex-husbands i r.i.p Travis Maldonado too
man
God cannot believe that guy shot himself
in the head Theo looks like he's on his
way to a DUI arraignment
second prize throwing that out there man
let me write that let me say the names
of the people that that did this
Daniel Stubbs that congresswoman and
Josef Ackermann and that's it let me see
what else yeah I'll look like a long way
yeah hold on a DUI arraignment and
either wear something nice cuz I don't
keep I don't really you know I don't I'm
not I don't get her like a ton of nice
stuff so I like to have just a couple
nice things uh what else you look I know
this is a little bit egomaniacal to be
to be uh just reading things about
yourself but some of this is pretty
funny Theo looks like a gun-toting
Jehovah's Witness you want the lord do
you want the lord
shame YouTube made Thea remove the first
video I think it was but just because
they we had an editing issue
Theo don't stop with these kind of
guests this is awesome guesting dude is
and knowledgable in guns he knows a lot
about guns that's what struck me about
him you know is that he knew a lot about
guns so you got to know that he was
still waiting on his background check
and told this guy I'm not afraid to eat
someone well well I'm not I'll be lying
to you if I said I was afraid of that
kind of [ __ ] you know I'm not afraid I'm
not afraid to survive man
so gang [ __ ] man somebody said but he's
I knew oh sorry who wrote that uh that
was Kyla Smith Kayla Smith this guest
looks like Brendan Fraser's long-lost
son gang and that's Megan durak that
facts he really did look like him uh
that's great that's great
[Music]
he looks like a lesbian guidance
counselor thank you actually that's
pretty cool actually
[Music]
[Music]
let me see I can totally see Theo asking
out cat at gunpoint yeah while and
pumpkins I said that he wasn't a gun so
much now he's even reloading his videos
that's great and that's Jo PO jo P oh
[Laughter]
man that's crafty man that's craft he
did uh what else
Theo looks like he thinks he's going in
for a job interview at a
telecommunication company but really
it's for the KKK
that's hilarious I could see yeah if
somebody's in the KKK and they had to be
working desk I could see him wearing a
shirt like that Thea what guns did I buy
Vaughn that [ __ ] is hilarious dude I
forgot man I forgot because when you
leave they should let you have a picture
of the gun when you leave because when
you leave you just you don't have any
you know you don't have any memory of
the gun we have a memory of the gun but
you don't have any like a card that says
exactly what gun you bought so it's like
they should you know it's it be cool if
they had a little picture like hey this
is what you you know what you have so
you could you know you know just every
now and then be like oh yeah this is
what I'm gonna get
[Music]
uncle Theo is gonna kill crystally after
their Instagram battle the other day
praise God brother well look man the
battle against the dark arts never ends
brother and you know that and I know
that
so Theo looks like he's going in the Oh
looks like he's going to an interview at
Supercuts hilarious dude
Theo looks like Patrick Swayze some
stunt stunt double whatever that is but
he's only does the homoerotic love
scenes that's crazy man uh let me see
what else we got here
kane 2024 yes we Kane I thought that was
pretty cute well we'll finish it up
right here this from John Caitlin do is
gonna play that one-armed lesbian in
tiger King the motion picture and that's
from John Kaitlyn right there dropping
that frickin that hitter do is dressed
like my dentist I look like a dentist at
a church that's what I look like bro I
look like this method I look like I'm
method dentist man
he has never had Craig block visa oh my
god oh my god this is crazy man you guys
live in an alternate universe man
and that's from Jack proc a gentleman by
the name of Jack proc is his handle so
anyway man that's a lot I was out that I
mean that you can take this hair of you
one I didn't mean for this to be
egomaniacal I just sometimes some
comments are so funny and so wild that
that I I don't know I just want to read
them and just laugh and so and so I
thought I would do that what else man
not much else dude just hit an a a
meeting a little bit ago I'm about to go
on the roof and do some yoga I don't
want to do it but I I know that I need
to do it now much bought some coconut
water today what else today's the
one-year anniversary when I went to see
Dustin Poirier fight out there and in
Atlanta when he won that belt man Dan
that was crazy that was crazy man I
can't even just it's just wild to see
people achieve a piece of their dream
you know whatever that dream is and but
anyway I hope you guys had a happy
Easter it's such a oh just a different
time for Easter you know it's almost
like um I don't know for me you know I
was I didn't want to go back home to
visit my family because my stepdad I
didn't he's older you know and I just
didn't know um I don't know I just not
scared but I don't know if he's scared
or not so I don't want to you know
it's up to him you know really so but
you know I think it's a nice time in any
it makes me think about just the people
that I love and and someone try to spend
some extra time doing that this week
just thinking about people that I love
and and and what else anyway man I'm
digressing here but yeah I just wanted
to I wanted to just read through and
laughs I thought we could use an extra
laugh and you know over this past year I
haven't really felt that funny this past
year I felt very I've just been just
exhausted just exhausted man at a level
that I didn't even know I could be
exhausted at so to get to laughs and uh
and you guys to make me laugh that's
great so for me that's really really
great so thank you very much
and uh and you guys be good to
yourselves all right